hi this is dr gregory sadler
i'm a professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason i o
where we put philosophy into practice
i've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years
and i find that many people run into
difficulties reading classic
philosophical texts
sometimes it's the way things are said
or how the text is structured
but the concepts themselves are not
always that complicated and that's where
i come in
to help students and lifelong learners
i've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube
many viewers say they find them useful
what you're currently watching is part
of a new series of shorter videos
each of them focused on one core concept
from an important philosophical text
i hope you find it useful as well
in chapter three of his book philosophy
as a way of life
pure ado is concentrating on this
conception
of spiritual exercises and
it's it's very useful to look at
the types of spiritual exercises
that he delineates and distinguishes
from each other otherwise
there's a tendency to turn everything
into a spiritual exercise
and it all becomes kind of a mish-mash
we want to
be able to talk about broad categories
of
exercises that are different from
each other as you could say as genera as
types
but you know all have the same
basic point of reference and orientation
and which often reinforce each other
so as pure adult points out early on
in in this chapter in the first section
we don't actually have any completely
comprehensive and systematic treatises
of these spiritual exercises of these
different things that are identified as
here's what you need to do
in order to live philosophy you know to
do philosophy as the art of living
you know there there may in fact have
been such for say the stoic school
or you know for the later uh middle
and and uh neoplatonists or for the
epicureans
we we may have even had some for the
cynics we know that the cynics wrote
things
down and we don't have any of those
texts what we do have
are lots and lots and lots of illusions
not just to texts
and and you know textbooks you might
even say
but also to different outlooks
to practices to what different groups
are doing
we do have a lot of individual exercises
um some of which are found for example
in plutarch's treaty seas
and in epictetus or in other other
philosophers as well
and we even have some rather focused
treatises you could think about seneca's
you know
work on anger his work on benefits his
work
on the happy life each of these has lots
of
exercises within them or plutarch's on
the cessation of anger
which appears to have been you know
relying upon an earlier text by an
aristotelian philosopher
uh herodo manus or jerome who we don't
have and and so
you know we do have some focused works
but we don't we don't have any sort of
complete guide but that's okay um
ado says we do have some some listings
you know for example by
filo of alexandria he says thanks to him
we have two lists of spiritual exercises
and these are lists of kinds
of or types of spiritual exercises so he
says
one of these lists enumerates the
following elements
research zetasis in in greek which means
seeking something out thorough
investigation
skepticism reading on agnosis
listening across attention
self-mastery and kratea and
indifference to indifferent things the
other name successfully
reading meditations melatae therapies of
the passions
remembrance of good things self-mastery
and the accomplishment of
duties and he says we can use these to
give a brief description of stoic
spiritual exercises
uh and and so that's what what he does
next but he says we'll study the
following groups in succession first
attention
then meditations and remembrance is good
things and the more intellectual
exercises
finally the more active exercises
so you know this is actually
quite a lot of different techniques
or exercises however you want to frame
them
that we can look at individually and ado
says that
we should look at the stoics why the
stoics is it because the stoics are
completely right about everything
no but we we see this spiritual exercise
tradition
at least in the text that we still have
if the epicurean texts
uh hadn't been so many of them hadn't
been lost maybe we'd be better off
but we see it more developed in in the
stoics
so he says that we can look at attention
as the first thing prosoque attention
which you could also translate as
mindfulness if you like that
contemporary term he says
is the fundamental stoic spiritual
attitude it's a continual vigilance and
presence of mind self-consciousness
which never sleeps
and a constant tension of the spirit now
that's that's a stoic way of talking
about it
it's not as if other schools don't also
in their own way stress attentiveness or
attention
or mindfulness but they may not frame it
in terms of
tension itself right
what does it do he says thanks to this
attitude the philosopher is fully aware
of what they do at each instant and they
will their actions fully they can be
committed
to their action thanks to spiritual
vigilance the stoic always has at hand
the fundamental distinct rule of life
that is the distinction between what
depends on us
and what does not which epictetus takes
as being very important
ado also takes is very important earlier
stokes
actually didn't talk that much about
that they talked about a lot of other
things but you could talk about
attention
to those rules of life as well
so he says as an epicureanism so for
stoicism it's essential
that adepts be supplied with a
fundamental principle formulable in a
few words
extremely clear and simple so they can
keep it in mind
and we could he says we could also
define this attitude as concentration on
the
present moment so what does
attentiveness
prosoque actually do for the stoic he
says
it's it's the key to spiritual exercises
one reason
is because it frees us from the passions
which
are and here he says something a little
bit curious always oriented towards the
past or the future
and to things that don't depend on us
now that's a curious thing to say
i'm i'm telling you because in the stoic
categorization of the passions
as a matter of fact a lot of the
passions are responses to what is
believed
correctly or incorrectly to be present
right present good thing present bad
thing
but we'll put that aside for for a
moment um ado is not recommending a sort
of like living totally in the present
man and you know new agey kind of ways
but there there is an importance in
freeing ourselves
from you know past and future that are
not particularly helpful for us and he
also says it allows us
being attentive to respond immediately
to events
and here's a really interesting turn of
phrase as if they were questions asked
all
of a sudden adobe views a lot of this
in terms of sort of dialogue and
dialectic between the self
and the self and others and and the
world so
you know viewing the challenges that
we're facing as questions put to us by
the world makes
perfect sense so that is uh an important
set of spiritual exercises
next we get into things that are a bit
more structured
and you could even say a bit more
deliberately
cognitive so he talks about memorization
neme in greek and meditation malayte on
the rule of life
now it's not just meditation on the rule
of life there's all sorts of meditative
or contemplative exercises that
are intended to prepare us for
particular
types of situations or to help us better
understand
who we are and he says that it will
allow us to be ready at the moment when
an unexpected circumstance occurs so
he uses as a prime example prime
meditation malorum the
thinking about bad things in advance
which is
you know it's a very important stoic
practice it's used in other
traditions as well which may have gotten
it from the stoics some of which
definitely didn't get it from the stoics
but that can be helpful now one of the
things that adobe brings up
here again is that there is a linguistic
component to this he says
what we need are persuasive formula or
arguments
epi logismoy which we can repeat to
ourselves in
difficult circumstances so as to check
movements of fear anger
or sadness we can also do things like
first thing in the morning we go over in
advance what we have to do during the
day in the evening
we engage in self-examination and adult
goes on to say
meditation is an attempt to control
inner discourse
an effort to render it coherent
so the meditation that he's talking
about here is not just
emptying your mind it's actually
trying to empty some of your mind so
that you can fill it with stuff that's
actually
going to serve you better and which you
can
build together in a coherent system
now the third type of exercise that he
talks about
broad category it provides nourishment
for
meditation and memorization what do you
meditate on what do you
what do you memorize he says
well reading listening research
and investigation also reading can
include
explanation of specifically
philosophical
texts so studying research and
investigation he says
are the results of putting instruction
into
practice for example we're to get used
to defining objects and events from a
physical point of view
we must picture them as they are when
situated within the cosmic hole
we can dissect events to reduce them
into their elements a prime example of
this
is in marcus aurelius when he's saying
oh you see that you know really
tasty dish in front of you break it down
into its components
and you'll see that it's really not that
you know
impressive and might even be a little
gross quite frankly
you know uh this is this is a common
practice so that
that fits into these specifically
intellectual exercises
we do these in a general sense we do
these in specific senses
as well and this is quite interesting if
hadou is correct about this
then you can't just practice a
philosophy as a way of life you have to
actually
study a philosophy as a way of life and
it has to be an
ongoing practice of reading and study
which interestingly enough is what the
ancient stoics actually told us
isn't it it's only modern stoics who
some of them want to dispense with this
this aspect
finally we get to the thing that a lot
of people are much more interested in
practical
exercises intended to create
habits and he says some of these are
very much interior
you know not just about exterior things
and very close to the
thought exercises we've just discussed
for example
indifference to in different things is
nothing other than the application of
the fundamental rule
other exercises like self-mastery
fulfilling duties and social life
those require us to actually do
something they require practical
forms of behavior and there's a lot of
things that are kind of in between you
know trying to
wean yourself away from automatic
thought processes and responses that
produce
anger or sadness or fear anxiety
and towards you know adopting a more
detached
attitude towards these things that's
kind of in the middle it's both interior
and exterior but these practical
exercises
the goal is indeed to create habits
also to undo older habits that are not
serving us well those that subject us to
the passions those that
have us engaging too quickly in
processes of reasoning about
impressions that are coming in now
what's really interesting here
is these are not strictly just stoic
right we could look at the epicureans
we could look at the cynics what we know
of them we can even look at the cyranic
hedonist school which we don't have
any any texts of but just you know
testimonies about
and we can see a lot of these exercises
being carried out but in different ways
so for example
the epicureans don't suggest that people
should engage in
prime meditation malorum because they
don't think we want to
try to make ourselves you know uh think
about things that are that are
disturbing and troubling and make us sad
or angry
instead we ought to think about past
pleasures or
pleasures yet to come we should we
should direct our mind in different ways
so there's you know a different
meditation going on and perhaps
also different intellectual exercises
going on
but they're all doing this whether
they're platonists
stoics epicureans or even you know uh
eclectics of some sort a little bit
later he talks about the epicureans
as you know treating pleasure
itself as a spiritual exercise now
how do you do that well by enjoying
pleasures
in a thoughtful rational refined sort of
way
and also by using these other spiritual
practices to strip away
some of the fears and troubles that
beset people
so that they can as a dough is going to
say the epicureans thought that we have
joy
just in existing and so
that's that's another possibility he
also talks about in a
very interesting section uh where he's
discussing dialogue he tells us that
the socratic dialogue turns out to be a
kind of communal
spiritual exercise interlocutors are
invited to participate in such
inner spiritual exercises as examination
of conscience
right meditation mindfulness and
um attention to oneself and this this
ties in with you know
self-knowledge of the relationship of
the self to itself
and learning how to dialogue with
oneself so there are some
important practices in that respect that
we also see coming up within the stoics
and then there's a discussion about
training for death
as another you know we could call it not
not a sub type of spiritual
practices but as involving these
different types as well you know you
could be attentive to the fact that
life is passing away right you can
broaden your perspective
uh through how you think about things so
that you can
realize that that your own death is
nothing absolutely unique
you can learn about you know what the
philosophers have to say
you can engage in practical exercises
so that you'll have some self mastery
when you're in dangerous situations
you can persevere in them so there's a
number of
different types of spiritual practices
and each school develops and deploys
its own particular practices many of
them borrow
from each other you know because why
uh miss out on something that's quite
good if somebody else has developed an
excellent spiritual practice that
that you can make use of i'll give you
one prime example of this that's spread
across the you might say the curriculum
of ancient philosophy
bringing before the eyes uh your
you know a conception of what you look
like when you become
angry so that you realize oh that's
pretty
ugly that may actually help to wean you
away from the anger response we find it
in
epicureans we find it in stoics we find
it in middle plateness
and in others as well because it's turns
out it's an effective technique
right so there's there's a lot of
overlap between these but we can
distinguish
these apart from each other and just to
reinforce the point
it's very important that we do
distinguish them because they're not all
the same
thing and we want to know well what part
of the mind or
body or soul or whatever it is that
we're working upon
are we actually engaging and what sort
of specific
content or direction are we giving it
you